[Music]
john starts off this hour he's in
colorado hi john how are you
how you doing dave appreciate you taking
my call sure man what's up
well uh i've been an on-off listener to
you for for a few years now and uh i
think i don't think i've ever heard this
question posed to you before uh what do
you guys have advice for somebody that's
kind of living with the death sentence
and if i may um
give you a little brief overview of what
my situation is
sure
well um when i was born i was born with
my leg you know shorter than my other
one i went through a bunch of surgeries
the first one i was seven days old i
went through about 13 more went to the
shriners hospital which was a great
facility there in houston texas got
fixed up with my leg well ended up with
an autoimmune liver disease my body
started thinking my liver was a bad
thing and it was probably due to all
those anesthesias drugs etc etc
so i ended up getting an autoimmune
disease since i was 17 i'm about to turn
50 years old dave here in april
my mom and dad uh they've been marrying
53 years i've had a very strong uh you
know
church bound uh very strong family
behind me my mom told me that i had a
brain just because i couldn't dig
ditches i wasn't going to be some ssi
kid and uh she was gonna make me use my
brain so i you know went through college
they didn't have much i had to keep my
grades up to pay for all my schooling uh
i did become an mri tech i've been an
mri tech now for 28 years but i've been
having this ah a roller coaster ride of
uh you know off and on to these meds and
uh
seven years ago i was probably you know
up for a liver transplant i refused to
do that day because i'm just playing out
tired but i did my own research and i
found a way to fix myself and it bought
me about another seven years well here i
am at seven years my condition is
getting worse
now uh i make seventy uh seven thousand
seven hundred ninety one dollars and
eighty one cents a year uh i can only
afford to pay uh put 10 in my 401 k but
i've had to pay you know the route that
i decided to save myself with the
insurance doesn't pay of course so you
know that i took a big hit seven years
ago so i only got about maybe forty
thousand in my 401 k my i only can
afford to put ten months because it cost
me about two to three hundred dollars in
supplements and so forth and so forth so
uh your your your plan doesn't seem to
be a viable plan for
someone like me i they're telling me now
that i probably got maybe another seven
eight years i don't have any debt other
than i just bought a town home last year
i just paid off my car i'm looking for
another beater because right now you
don't want to buy a car right now
because the prices are through the roof
so i'm just kind of hoping this thing
lasts me for a while uh i do have a
small little rock ira with only about
fifteen hundred dollars and or i'm sorry
three thousand dollars in it i stopped
going there because uh i wasn't fine uh
comfortable with my financial advisor
that was advising there so i just
stopped contributing to it for the as a
point um
so i'm basically sitting here thinking
that i have a
life insurance i want to be able to
leave
my niece and my nephew something and my
sister my parents are in their 70s i'm
close to them
so i go down take care of them best i
can
but like i'm saying is uh
i know i'm never going to be a rich
person i just don't even have the time
to do it
but i uh i want to be able to find uh
it's been difficult to me because i want
to find some financial advice that
somebody's not appreciative of my
situation john i i um
i can't imagine facing what you've been
facing i mean you've been a fighter
you've been a fighter your whole life
um
you know every time every time they tell
you you're done you get another seven
years is the story i heard so i'm not
sure you're as done as you're
describing um
and i i suspect that something will come
along because and if it does you'll find
it
that will be a way to do this um
so here's the thing well basically
my question is dave
my question is basically dave is i want
to be able to make sure i'm not wasting
money on all these insurances and
stuff that i got crap like that i want
to be able to leave them something but
still i want to be able to enjoy my life
right now you're not wasting money on
insurance if it's taking care of you
okay and taking care of you is more
important than you leaving a niece or a
nephew or something i have like aflac
policies and i know you're not a fan of
those you know when i have crap like
that then get ready
don't get rid of them well i don't get
good health insurance work your plan
i have it through my work okay i have it
through my work you know i have all that
said i just want to make sure that you
got the wrong goal
your goal of leaving your niece and
nephew money is the wrong goal the right
goal is take care of you
i'm fine right now no you're not
you're not you're not fine you don't
have any money you don't have any margin
in what you're talking about and you're
sitting here telling me that the idea of
living on lesson you make and avoiding
debt and building up wealth is not for
you well it is for you
do you have exactly the same timeline as
everyone else no you don't
um you but you're a fighter i guess
that's what you're a scrapper and you
know what i would do is i would have you
build up savings
stay out of debt
which you have done a great job of
and uh you know don't don't leave a
bunch of debt behind but don't worry
about having an insurance policy for a
niece or a nephew you need to take care
of you
and what money you can scrape together
let's spend on your health and on some
solutions and on some life extension
things and something quality of life
things and spend that on you and that is
not selfish
you have been dealt a hand of cards and
you've been a scraper and a fighter and
you've done a great job i'm very proud
of what you've pulled off
but i disagree with your premise that
our plan doesn't work for you maybe
you're going to adjust some of the
nuances of it but our plan is save money
live on less than you make be generous
live on a plan a written budget stay out
of debt that's our plan and you've done
that by and large so you've done a good
job ken yeah i agree john i i think that
you feel some sense of pressure and i
think you have to let go of that find
out why you feel this pressure to to
leave something behind for your niece
and nephew there's nothing wrong with
that that's very good-hearted but i also
think that it's created a narrative that
dave has has really enlightened you to
and and you don't need to feel that you
if you want to live a life that you
enjoy and have a quality of life which
is what you just said a moment ago i
think you have the finances all ready to
do that and i think that's what you
focus on and then if there is something
left over get a good financial advisor
one of our smart investor pros it does
have the heart of a teacher let them
guide you you understand everything
they're guiding you on and then you'll
leave it behind but seven years seven
years or seventeen years from now when
someone steps into the pulpit and
delivers your eulogy
it needs to be
john was a fighter
john was a scrapper he's self-sustained
he always took care of himself and he
was always generous
not he left money to his niece and
nephew
this is not where your greatness comes
from your greatness comes from who you
already are john